good morning Hank it's Tuesday so when
we think of Africa we often think of it
as one place right you know it's this
poor disease-ridden continent where
people live in thatched roof huts and
children don't get good education and
then there's like a tiny wealthy elite
most of whom we're overly decorous
military uniforms smoke cigars and
laughs about all of the aid that they're
embezzling but ya know for one thing
Africa isn't just one place most
Canadians live closer to Venezuela than
Liberians live to Botswana but for
another those stereotypes are just
ridiculous I mean I did meet a lot of
people who live in thatched roof huts
and Ethiopia and a lot of children who
didn't have access to good schools and
corruption remains a significant problem
but just as Ethiopia's poverty rate is
falling it's middle class is rising more
and more kids go to primary school in
the main university in Addis Ababa which
in 1950 had 32 students today has more
than 42,000 and when I was in Ethiopia I
got to meet a bunch of them with Bill
Gates including this young woman Mecca
red who started an anti Domestic
Violence initiative basically a group of
volunteers that that want to see a
better community and don't want to see a
better country and a better society so
we wait until we work on gender-based
violence so yeah Ethiopia has
anti-domestic violence activists and
insurance agents and web developers and
nurses and et cetera okay I want to give
you a sense of some of these students
like these two young women are pre-med
and they talked a lot about the risks
and opportunities of working abroad
there's anyone they won't come back the
other students were future engineers and
dwars and a couple people who weren't
sure what they wanted to do yet you know
like me in college I waited until like
three minutes into the conversation
before I asked if they watched YouTube
you want videos on YouTube yeah for
boners Hank for fun and for school these
people are nerdfighters if ever I have
seen one but this brings up an
interesting problem which is that the
internet in Ethiopia is crazy slow I
mean like yeah
that that makes it hard to watch a lot
of creators it makes it hard to comment
it also takes forever for tumblr to load
and we talked about how that makes it
hard to be an active participant in
online communities almost all of their
social media interaction happens with
people they know in real life for which
I said what is real life it was also
interesting to talk to them about
platforms like I asked this future
engineer what social media he uses
that's right and college students all
over the world are so over Facebook also
just like I hear from a lot of American
students these students felt a lot of
tension between like what they dreamt of
doing and what they'd been told they
should do although in their case it
wasn't just about parental wishes or
future job opportunities there was also
a kind of larger sense of responsibility
and I also heard a lot of concern which
I'm sure some nerdfighters can relate to
that book-learning might not translate
to real world success you know I gotta
be lost in different subjects I know how
to do integrations better how could I
just express that in reality Hank I
think we have to pause quickly here just
to note the astonishing zit on the side
of my neck are you sentient zip do you
have a soul anyway so after meeting with
these students I went to the library's
bathroom where there was a bucket full
of water that you had to pour into the
tank in order to make the toilet flush
because there is no running water in the
library Hank there isn't just one
Ethiopia the college library with no
water is Ethiopia but these future
engineers who will build the city's
infrastructure are also Ethiopia these
kids are Ethiopia and so is this doctor
and so are these farmers and so is this
presidential marching band now I know
that when we see Africa on the news or
in the movies it's always like war
pirates refugees disease but the stories
I saw in Ethiopia were far more
complicated and ultimately more
compelling these remarkable young people
have seen the greatest drops in poverty
rates and infant mortality in their
country's history but every year in
Ethiopia tens of thousands of children
still die of easily preventable diseases
and if we've learned one thing from
global health in the last 20 years it's
that if those kids don't die and they
don't have to then they can grow up and
end up studying in that library I'll see
you on Friday